[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
while speaking about vaccination efforts
this week president biden said
we've got to take the next step together
and
i speak for all of us when i say don't
you let that man take a step alone
help him stop help stop moving
what is happening
[Laughter]
it looked like a gift but it wasn't and
that was just how it goes
the same thing sometimes happens over
and over again naturally i appreciate
his determination
but slow it down i may not be with you
when you get
not the mountaintop it's just stairs i
have been
at the top of the zoo
[Laughter]
you guys it was announced this week that
kentucky derby winner medina spirit
failed a post-race drug test
it's the worst thing to happen to medina
spirits since that tiny man beat his ass
for two minutes
national twilight zone day was this week
or was it
it was it was announced this week that a
broadway musical called
mj that was inspired by the life of
michael jackson will open in december
making it the first musical to start
with a man coming out on stage and going
man look
according to bloomberg
so much so much he's gonna start off
looking one way
man look i need you to suspend disbelief
okay
there's gonna be a monkey at some point
let it go
get too close to that monkey according
to bloomberg
billionaire jeff bezos is buying a new
417-foot
super yacht that includes an additional
support yacht
so don't tell me the pandemic hasn't
affected everyone
lex luthor asks with your lex luthor ass
yacht needing a yacht
students at a university in new jersey
i've begun caring for more than 800 baby
sea turtles that were recently
discovered
in a storm drain but just until they can
be returned to their dad
oh yes there he is he's going to love
him
yeah and teach him the way he will the
way of pizza
the way and finally
the 1990s nickelodeon series legends of
the hidden temple will be rebooted as an
adult version
it's called legends of the sample
and that was the monologue tarek are you
liking the show so far
i am great because we have more
it was announced recently that the
popular 90s toy tamagotchi
will return to stores this summer oh man
remember those derek
of course i remember i still have mine
his name's randall whoa did you find it
in an old drawer or something
no i i found it in my pocket i mean how
else would i
care for it and feed it if it was locked
in an old drawer
wait you've been taking care of your
tamagotchi all these years
well yeah haven't you derek
my tamagotchi died in 1997 45 minutes
after i bought it
and i haven't looked at it since wow
why that's what everyone did do you hear
yourself
that doesn't make it not up that
tamagotchi was your responsibility
that little egg was relying on you to
guide it into this world and you killed
it in 45 minutes
shame amber shame okay i'm sorry
jeez it was kind of a pain in the ass to
keep it alive
oh really it was too much to ask for you
to feed it
and to play with it and to discipline it
and to give it snacks
and to administer medicine to it and to
take it for walks
and to clean up his droppings and to
nurture it every few minutes of every
day for 25 years
yes that was way too much to ask
well that's a shame i've had randall
here for the better part of three
decades and it's been no trouble at all
wait you've had to nurture that thing
every few minutes for 25 years
that's right but tarek this sketch has
taken a few minutes
what are you insinuating randall
oh randall no goodbye
tarik you were a
what is it randall what is it
spit it out say it hey weirdo
ouch all right let's move on and give
tarik a minute to collect himself
thank you nasa announced recently that
they will be landing the first
person of color on the moon first
i know right can you believe that there
are still firsts out there for people of
color
i can but it's depressing well sure if
you look at it as a symptom of a white
supremacist society designed to keep
people of color as lower class citizens
then yes it's infuriating
or you could look at it as an
opportunity
are you thinking what i'm thinking i'm
gonna be the first person of course
do something sick
[Applause]
look at me i'm the first person of color
to do this
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to do this
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to say no
thank you
that's too much flavor
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to say
cool beans
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to sing
the regular birthday song
instead of the stevie wonder one happy
birthday to you
happy birthday to you
i'm the first person of color to say
candyman in the mirror three times
candyman candyman candyman
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to
download a coldplay album
[Applause]
i'm the first person to color their own
truck nuts
[Applause]
i'm the first person of color to not
two-step to frankie beverly and mays
not if i do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my dna to dance to the song
and that is science well we weren't able
to set that particular record but
we were still the first people of color
to do a lot of pretty impressive stuff
right tarek damn candyman got him
we've covered a lot so far tonight but
there's one more story i'd like to talk
about
governor andrew cuomo announced recently
that new york will begin a major
re-opening on may 19th
wow an open city what's that going to be
like
you know what it's been so long that i
can't quite remember
me either the streets have been so empty
for the past year
but now the city is going to be full of
people again i guess
yeah we will have to have a normal daily
routine
that involves leaving the house with
other
people wait a second guys
i think i'm starting to remember
you wake up you go to that place you've
been
a thousand times before
and there's a picture of a little coffee
cup
right on their front door what's that
place called again
starbucks that's right i'm starting to
remember
you walk to work it's quite a schlep
but there's this stuff you don't want on
your shoes so you
watch every step it's all dog [ __ ]
that's right it's everywhere we
can't wait to do it all
even the parts we can't recall cause
this city is
a stranger stares and holds his gaze
as i walk by him he shouts
a special phrase
i love the way that ass shake oh yeah
they yelled that a lot
you get to work in socialize
[Music]
that weird office girl talks about this
as she looks you
right in the eye oh the progression of
her foot fungus from treatable to
untreatable we find it
quite appealing
[Music]
[Applause]
i cannot wait to see my friends
to talk to the guy whose stories
never end
i'll visit my bodega and their cat
and i'll smile when the cashier says wow
[Music]
[Music]
enjoy the fear of an active shooter
we're gonna need a bigger bra the city
[Music]
oops
[Applause]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips
and a lot of digital exclusives and a
lot of this